you start run fast and then you just
continue running right faster faster and
faster and
so the the number one priority is to
continue to run
fast and as you do it you continue to
expand the offering of the product
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with louimi tech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel stanford
in startup all about motorcycles meet
uri lavi the ceo and co-founder of right
vision
ori is a passionate visionary and an
experienced motorcyclist
before right vision he was the ceo at
pix scout which he led the company
through multiple pivotal changes leading
to industry leadership recognition
prior to joining pick scout uri held
leadership positions at a variety of
other companies
ranging from startups to multinational
corporations in the media
insurance and homeland security sectors
he holds a bsc in software engineering
from the technion israel institute of
technology
uri lavi thank you for joining me today
how are you
good thank you thank you for having me
i'm surprised you're
you're not on a motorcycle as we're
talking it's it's not very
representative i have to say
actually i was riding to the office
today on a motorcycle so yeah
right i think one of the most uh
inspiring things that i'm that i'm
excited to talk about here is this
integration between a personal passion
of yours
and and you know making you know a
successful business
i believe that yeah i just saw the
jerusalem post that you're
you know listed on the forbes 2021 list
and in november you raised seven million
dollars for right vision
and but your your journey starts all the
way back from the tiffany on and you're
involved with quite a few companies
you were the vpr indian then and then
ceo of picscout and
and really what i want to spend these 20
minutes on is talking about your journey
from you know engineering to leadership
and and
most recently combining your passion and
you know your business skills into right
vision
so ori take me all the way back you know
to when you're starting out
what is sort of the passion that you're
bringing with you and do you know that
that you're destined to be now a
two-time serial ceo
not at all i don't think that that was
uh you know the beginning
as uh as all uh jewish families i think
you know the first thing that you have
been uh taught is uh
learn hard study hard and then work hard
and everything will be okay
and i think this is definitely one of
the um
i think one of the cliches i think that
we are
uh or at least initially i was uh
i was living by uh but slowly and
gradually as you
kind of mature and you uh you really
want to excel in what you're doing i
think that's that's the number one thing
that really goes you want to excel you
want to become better at what you're
doing
you're looking for more opportunities
and then you understand that
hey you know there are cool things that
you can build in the cool things that
you can do
and uh make no mistake it's it's cool
but it's
very hard i mean every time you're doing
that it's very very hard
right and so you're so today you're the
ceo and co-founder of right vision
first of all where does all that love
from motorcycles come from how do you
how do you explain that passion
i i do know that there's quite quite a
few people around the world that are
really passionate about
you know riding in motorcycles but but
i've yet to really understand
why why what's the you know the so the
big hype about it and maybe it's because
i've never been on a motorcycle myself
but can you share a little bit about
your
your interest in it yeah look uh
i mean motorcycle is definitely a cool
vehicle
it's very dangerous vehicle because you
know uh we
need to put we need to talk about the
elephant in the room um
and uh you know riding a motorcycle
uh it's a very cool experience if you do
it for leisure
you do it for your pleasure uh but
obviously the you know when you analyze
how people
utilize the motorcycle especially in
asian countries and some latin american
countries you
find that those vehicles have been used
for commute
so last night delivery you go to
european countries to the u.s
it's still being used for for the
commute and last mile delivery right
and you understand that there's a big
big gap
between where those vehicles are right
now and what they can do
especially when everybody talks about
autonomous vehicles and how to
write scars and nobody talks about
two-wheelers and that's exactly as an
entrepreneur you need to find a gap
right you need to find a
you know that that that small place
where uh everybody is talking about
something else but you can
easily take something that has been
applied in a different industry and find
that gap and then reapply that
but you need to apply reapply it smartly
so that's that's
how basically right vision started so
you're looking at you know this
this motorcycle leisure writing market
you're also saying but it's not just
leisure writing but it's actually you
know
a tool that is being used around the
world it's it's a tool that has
increased its usage
you know commercially for last mile
delivery and obviously you know we walk
the streets of tel aviv or
or in the united states especially also
in asia you see
and you know the streets are filled with
motorcycles and you realize that there's
a gap there while we spend a lot of
energy
and you know engineering and r d on you
know autonomous vehicles and four
wheeled vehicles
we're kind of leaving out this big gap
for motorcycles right
exactly exactly and i mean uh rightly so
because it's a challenging vehicle
there's a lot of uh
so it's not only so first you found the
gap you understand that you can reapply
something similar to that gap
but secondly uh you also need to create
a competitive advantage you need to
understand that it's not as simple just
copy
and paste because everybody can do it
right right so the second piece is
is to understand whether it's really gap
that is
hard to to build and hard to to to fix
and if the answer is yes then and you
know that you can fill this gap
and there's definitely something there
that you can take uh
off the ground and launch into something
with that
so why is it more difficult why is you
know building a technology for
safer motorcycle experience why is that
more difficult
than you know what's been done for for
four wheeled vehicles until now
well uh the multiple multiple reasons to
add to it first
uh it's a completely different
maneuverability if you think about the
bike
it vibrates all the time when you
accelerate it tilts
up and down uh you can move your
handlebar
uh you lean the bike all the time so in
terms of technology you actually
applying a lot
of transformations in the perceptive
environment and then the bike itself
zigzags within the traffic comes very
close to the cars it's a completely
different maneuverability i always joke
that this is almost like a plane like an
aircraft but but
in much more congested environment that
you need to analyze everything and you
need to predict the trajectories and
then on the predictive
trajectories you will need to say
whether it's an alert yes or no
so it's very very difficult on that area
and then there's additional
segment which is it's a smaller vehicle
it's a very uh it's very poor vehicle it
doesn't have enough places to put
sensors it doesn't have compute power
it doesn't have energy so then
when you actually sum all those gaps you
realize
this is a very challenging task that you
need to solve
so it wasn't an easy decision let's go
into that gap to be honest uh
uh together with another co-founder that
i have here
at brightvision we actually debated that
whether we should pursue it or not it's
well it
and you know since it's a difficult and
tough task to accomplish
uh we understood it will be a good
uh a good place to be
because others will have challenges to
compete
right so talk to me a little bit about
the you know that that
inflection point where you're sitting
there with your co-founder you realize
it's a difficult problem
you realize that there's a gap in the
market how do you strategically go about
saying
okay well we're going full time on this
but what are the tests we have to set
what are the different you know limits
we have to set for ourselves to know
whether we're able to make this through
or not
well this is classical steps in each and
every product uh
you start with the customer so you
actually go
and we did we went to different agencies
and we set uh with actual bikers that
were coming and to purchase their new
bikes
and we started to ask questions so if
you have that system
what is what it will do for you what
will be enough what you actually wanted
to solve
okay you buy that and after after we
realized that there is a desire to buy a
system there is a
more or less a desire of functionality
that we have envisioned
as bikers ourselves as well then
you form the initial product strategy
so you understand what you need to
accomplish to solve it to provide that
and then you know that potential people
will be buying that again this is not
a research of uh one year right but
it's a good enough start a start point
that you gather
gathered enough feedback to say okay you
know that people will be buying that
there is a needed solution and you know
how to solve it
and after that you're actually sitting
down and start building the first
systems to do it and test it and uh
obviously get the feedback and
uh and so on and so on how important was
it here
throughout and obviously you know you're
in the middle of the journey but but how
important has it been that you're
a cyclist yourself or that you're a
writer yourself
do you think you would have been able to
do this if if you weren't one
uh yes uh i could do that probably with
the use with uh you know others other
experts and etc
but uh i think that even if you don't
have a full understanding
of of you know of the field you have to
learn it
so even with some background that i
obviously had
i still read a lot and uh and invested
my time to understand
you know different solutions options
other industries like the passenger cars
right the simple bicycles etc so you
learn all those
uh points and then you uh distill and
find out the best
strategies so there is obviously some
benefits to that
you still can do it without but it's
it's harder
right and i have to really and
understand this because i think one of
the things that i'm surprised most about
this
everything that you're saying so far
makes perfect sense to me right
writers love writing commercially it's
just
increasing as from what i can see at
least with my own eyes
the technology has been proven in other
industries and it's been
you know proven to be you know unicorns
and decacorns
when we're talking about the you know
the four wheeled vehicles and the
trucking industry
and yet you know motorcycles are even
more dangerous than all those it's even
more
important to have this technology on
motorcycles how come nobody picked up
the glove and said
i'm going to be i'm going to attempt to
be the market leader on this
well until right division of course
okay so so look i mean with every
industry you have
those uh uh those gaps so that's exactly
where entrepreneurs
uh thrives right so uh in this industry
uh i mean the motorcycle industry is the
the poor brother syndrome it's like the
younger brother syndrome
they're always one step behind both
right uh
there are always obvious challenges in
technology so because of the
maneuverability of the bike as i
explained before
any technology that comes in it's not a
simple copy
base so you really need to solve all
those challenges so it takes time
and just give you one uh couriers one
example an abs
which is a very proven uh product for
passenger car
uh was initially built in 1988 for a
motorcycle but then it became
commodity only in the last five years it
took about 16 to 20 years
to mature the product from the initial
staff to here
so it proves a little bit uh how
you know tough is technology for
motorcycles but then
because it's a smaller oem it's a
smaller industry and
the lack of money lack of attention
other issues that they wanted to
prioritize etc etc and that's where we
got
and the right vision was a beneficial of
that we are the first to enter where the
first to the market were first with the
product so
this in that case we we do enjoy uh you
know
filling this gap so as a you know as a
first mover's advantage how do you then
now is the ceo
position yourself to say okay i have to
you know
do this responsibly at the same time i i
do have to make sure that i'm always in
the forefront
and i'm guessing that you know you you
are you know all the time you have to
keep track okay what's happening in the
market how are people adapting
people are now realizing that this is a
great business what is
how does your focus as the ceo change as
you are you know right now the market
leader
the first movers advantage how do you
work on maintaining that
um honestly it's almost the same just
with a little bit more prioritization
you start to run fast and then you just
continue running right faster faster and
faster and
so the the number one priority is to
continue to run
faster and as you do it you continue to
extend the offering of the product
and by doing that you ensure that any
competition that will
uh will evolve will have a very hard
time to compete with you
uh and it's not that i'm not welcoming a
competition it's
actually good to have a competition
right always you know
makes you uh to think about what you're
doing what are you doing
yes how are you doing that and et cetera
but as
as you know strategically to continue
dominate you
prioritize what you want to have and you
continue to run
faster it's simple as it is
i want to you know go a little bit you
know 30 000 feet in the air and a little
bit higher level
about your experience as now a serial
ceo
you you've seen you know different
verticals within the industry with pig
scout
very very different from rideshare still
you are in two leadership positions
and you know with your you know your
experience in the military also as an
interrogator
you you're bringing also leadership
experience from from there as well and
you know
this human interaction what are some
patterns that you've observed
and the lessons that you've taken with
you throughout these years
that you would advise young
entrepreneurs just starting their
journey
whether it be in prioritizing focus
human reconnection strategy
whatever it may be that you've really
harnessed
yeah okay so i think 20 minutes will not
uh surface but i will try my best i mean
number one is people
number one esteem uh is the ability to
communicate and to be honest i mean as
as
when you're a small company it becomes
even
it allows you to run faster to be honest
it allows you to
uh smooth the barriers to remove the
barriers in communication to be on top
of everything
and this initial uh team that you have
is a team that is so so important to
great to initial bias
identification to continue to grow so
this is number one
uh as you continue to grow of course
there is
other things that start talking to took
a game right
but i would say the number one lesson is
the
the team and the people within the team
uh after that after that
the ability to innovate and to come with
the best product
is in my opinion number two uh again i'm
talking from a startup small company
perspective
right medium company perspective right
because once you become
really big then the execution matters
right you need to continue to execute
right so when you're looking at the team
the composition and you've
gotten to work with multiple teams what
what key figures do you notice or
or what is important to you as the
leader and in building this cohesive
team is it more about
you know the skill sets of the people is
it more about you know the
the vibe the culture that they're
creating because obviously every
group of people that you'll take or
every combination of people that you'll
create will have a different
you know working environment and
different vibes so what's what have you
seen
you know as a differentiator between
successful units of teams
versus unsuccessful ones
okay so up to 20 people i would say
it's all it's almost everything is
possible i mean you can bring
almost anybody and because you have that
personal interaction
and you walk together and you have uh
out of those 20 x number of people that
are always pushing they are always
engaged with
a lot of energy things will be more or
less okay as you continue to scale
you need to find those people that have
that positive energy all the time
but not in a bad way i mean you can
always find the person that is always
positive
have has lots of energy but it's just
not in the right place
right you have that hard-working person
within energy that continues to deliver
and
continues to figure out what to do next
and and be
we have that you know uh notion in
hebrew big head
right it's like but that's that's it
right i mean with that
positive energy of thinking you know
there's so many tough and difficult
pieces that will be happening to to
start up
as a team as a founder uh
and you need to maintain some some of
that positivity all the time despite all
the partnership
and the people that you bring if they
continue to be more
less like that that will continue to
be executed and scaled even beyond the
20 people to 40 50 60 100
center after 100 people there is another
thing that we need to do in the
organization so you know there is a rule
of
tribe i don't know whether you covered
that in the past but up to 120 people
yeah okay so there's research that has
been done that
a company under 120 people
still acts as a tribe so a leader will
be knowing
everybody almost by name there will be
some sort of interaction so the company
will be more or less okay
after 120 people uh a company usually
loses the focus then you have lots of
attrition
people leaving the company lots of uh
you know replacements new people
training
and that's actually a human wired
behavior
because the tribe um in both 120 it's
already not a small tribe it's a village
it's
a city right that you need to manage so
you need to scale it to a different
uh different organizational kind of
execution you will need to have
more uh uh leaders in the organization
more people pulling you know will need
to have
more communication down there is another
one that you will need to apply
i love it uh orie i think that what
first of all what you're doing with
with right vision is amazing i think you
know beyond the the cool features that
it provides to the
to this to the rider it provides a sense
of security provides the security
and with the with incredible features
that you have and i also just
really appreciate the technological
barriers that there are here
and that it's in a different type of
vehicle you have to make it lightweight
you have to make it portable you have to
make it resilient
to you know anything that you know that
the rider goes through
and in the ride and i think that it's it
this ingenuity of
finding that gap in the market tackling
that gap
and you know executing it on a really
really great product having that first
mover's advantage
and i honestly can't wait to see it in
all the bicycles and all the motorcycles
that i see down
in the streets of tel aviv and also
thank for thank you for sharing your
insights as to you know the
your leadership style and the importance
of being in the team and the importance
of of understanding really what is your
focus and what is your priority
before we finish i have to ask you the
most important question which is
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
okay working hard
but with energy working hard
okay so that we yeah so we we came with
five words so
there's a bunch of hyphens working hard
i love it thank you very very much best
of luck with the right vision
i can't wait to see the product in
action and best of luck
thank you thank you very much appreciate
that